Speaker 1: This you have to see. Elise Stefanik,
Republican congresswoman from New York,
explains how. What Mike Pence did was fine and
Trump was treated unfairly for the documents,
documents, stuff. But Joe Biden is a national
security threat. That's that's the real issue
here. There are three stories here. Two of
them, the Republican ones, are not a concern,
but the Biden one. That is the real issue. Let's
take a look at this. And she starts talking about
a weaponized FBI and blah, blah, blah, blah, blah,
folks. We have three situations. We can analyze
them pretty clearly. And this is not the way
that the line is that the the the what would. I'm
searching for a metaphor here. Let's just listen.
Speaker 4: In the case of Vice President Mike
Pence, he came forward and proactively reached
out and is following the process in the case of
Joe Biden. She has had classified documents
going back to his time in the Senate where
he started serving before I was born.
So this is a long standing national
security threat. Setting aside the very
important fact that Hunter Biden had access
and used as his home address,
where those classified documents
were improperly and illegally stored.
Speaker 1: Does she realize the number of people
that have access at Mar a Lago? Like if she's
concerned that Hunter Biden sometimes went to his
dad's house. She is going to be stunned to learn
what happens at Mar a Lago with regard to who
could have had that have had access to the boxes
of documents that Trump directed to have place
down there. We don't even have evidence Biden
knew he had this stuff. We don't have evidence.
Pence knew he had the stuff. Let's continue.
Speaker 4: This will be a part of the oversight
agenda right on the House Intelligence Committee.
We absolutely want to make sure we have all of
the facts. It is a concern. We've seen it with
our president, Donald Trump, with Biden friends
that, you know, some of the top leaders just
aren't handling classified information at all.
Unidentified: Should there be some sort
of foreign spouse, top leaders, contacts?
Well, let's.
Speaker 4: Highlight the difference
here in what the consequences have been. You
had the FBI raid, Mar a Lago. You did not see
any of that happen for President Joe Biden.
Speaker 1: You know why? You know why there
was a different handling because the legal law
enforcement authorities trying to get the Trump
documents back spent months trying to get them
back through other means with Biden and with
Pence. In Pence's defense, Pence did the same
thing. There would be no opportunity for a raid
or search warrant to be executed because the
amount of time between when the documents were
found and turned over was so small. That's why
they're among many other reasons. By the way.
Speaker 4: We did this. What also is
different is President Trump as president
has the right to declassify documents.
Speaker 1: That that's a ruse. Okay.
He has the right to. He didn't. And legal
experts are almost unanimous on the fact
that just saying pack up my documents and send
them to my house does not de facto declassify
them just because the president doesn't.
Speaker 4: So the media should cover the
fact that the FBI has been weaponized against
President Trump and clearly has covered up for
sitting President Joe Biden.
Speaker 1: What of rhetorical pretzel
that Elise Stefanik has wedged herself into?
It may not shock you that Elise Stefanik was
a gleeful endorser of George Anthony Kit. Tara
devoted there. SANTOS You know who I'm talking
about, right? The guy who invented the heart
transplant technique and built the Eiffel Tower.
That George Santos. Anyway, she was lovingly,
gleefully, and in Dorsey, an endorser, rather,
of Santos. Shouldn't come as a huge shock at
some point. I actually do think that this will
maybe not backfire on Republicans, but just fall
flat. And what I mean by that is if you look at
polling and approval polling so far, Joe Biden
has been unaffected by the classified documents
situation. My guess as to why is that the American
people realize there is no evidence of any kind
of malicious intent or subterfuge. Whereas the
Trump situation is dramatically different and
Trump's approval continues to suffer, I think
the American people are actually smart enough
to know. And that's a phrase that's often used by
Republicans to say. I believe the American people
are smart enough to realize what's B, you know,
when socialism is over. It just really genuinely
seems as though people realize the difference
between the Trump document story and the Pence
Biden stories, which right now look relatively
similar, although differences may come up in the
future. Let me know your thoughts. Is it clear
to you? That we are dealing with dramatically
different situations here. In terms of Trump,
Biden and Pence with these documents, or do you
think that it's basically all the same thing? Let
me know. Make sure you're subscribed on YouTube at
YouTube.com slash The David Pakman Show and make
sure you're following me on Twitter at Pacman.